[Music]
hero missions
are probably one of the things that's
the hardest to wrap your head around if
you've never
played one of them
[Music]
the goal around hero missions is for
these to be
this co-op pve experience
i personally only play competitive mode
like i'm all about that competition
and i have friends that they don't want
to do that at all so i'm really looking
forward to a game that i can play hours
and hours with with my friends who
aren't in competitive and it's also
something that
i'm interested in hero missions are the
content that people are playing
as they are leveling up their heroes and
so for
a system like this to really sing you
need
a lot of mission we don't want players
who feel like they're just in this grind
to get to the top
and there's a lot of really really good
back end technology that we're exploring
so the heroes are constantly bringing
their personality
and some light story to these hero
missions as well
the goal is to make as many as possible
hundreds
of hero missions we've explored a lot of
different ways of getting
to that much content so have like
different sets of enemy units that
people
will be fighting against and there's
different hero mission types
at the same time hero missions can take
place in all of the multiplayer maps
that we've done
and we're also adding new spaces onto
some of these maps
it's a huge challenge for the art team
we take maps that
a lot of people love and recognize and
we have to add a lot
more art and level design to it in this
one
hero mission play test we came up to an
area in king's row that usually has a
gate on it
suddenly that gate opened and i saw a
new
area of king's row that i had never seen
before
you may be playing a payload game type
and the payload may decide to take this
new route instead of
going the usual route that was really
really cool it was like this eye-opening
special moment
lan our lead tech artists on the
environment side
very early on our own free time made a
prototype
of a sandstorm on the temple of anubis
map and at the time we didn't know what
we wanted to do with that but it looked
awesome
we looked at it and went oh my god we
absolutely have to do this
so we put some new technology in place
that allows us to do this dynamically
you start the mission off
clear day midway through the mission
suddenly this
sandstorm or heavy weather would show up
it made the world just feel so much more
alive
there's a sunset daytime nighttime but
depending on where you are in the world
these look different
california or hollywood would have what
we call a california sun
new bonnie there's a great african sun
that happens there
you start to get a sense of space and
mood this is what really
brings the levels to life for me the
dynamic world's exciting just seeing
these dramatic
landscapes the wind and the atmosphere
blowing by
it's a much more cinematic experience
for the player
before you start a mission you look at a
map it's nighttime in
necropolis or there's a sandstorm in
necropolis
players can make some comp choices based
on knowing this information
characters like hanzo or widowmaker
start to be a little more valuable
because they have
abilities that allow them to see through
the sand more clearly
are we gonna talk about any of the types
of objectives
in hero missions yeah let's let's talk
about the objectives
players are being asked to do different
things from one hero mission to the next
so that they all feel
really fresh to the player for example
we have gathering return where you're
trying to go and grab these different
canisters to kind of safeguard them so
they don't go off and affect the
population in a negative way
it creates this really cool tension in
the world where on the one hand you're
trying to split
up and go grab all these canisters to be
as efficient as possible
but at the same time now you're having
these sort of special enemy units spawn
that are really difficult and if you
kind of get caught by yourself
it turns into a pretty bad situation
really quickly it feels extremely
cooperative and like a very different
way to interact with the overwatch
universe
we're experimenting with all sorts of
ideas and just internally we have names
like
wall of death scavenger hunt and kill
quests and
all these new mechanics and enemies for
people to experience
players will be able to jump in night
after night play
different hero missions and then work
through the progression system
leveling up their heroes
[Music]
you